hey guys how's it going happy Easter
today Jenna and I are going to do the
not my arms egg decorating challenge is
that an actual challenge it's an actual
challenge I'm not sure if anybody has
done egg decorating before we gotta
somehow put your arm in here okay push
her I mean okay hold on this arm in here
no no this one no like you're gonna put
this on actually just put this on like
I'm gonna put this on and then I'm gonna
zip it but then my arms have to go in
here can you move my hair no right here
oh yeah okay thank you I'm not sure you
have I know I don't have a bigger I'm
sure you have a bigger sweatshirt
look I'm so here okay are we good okay
we need a bigger sweatshirt
we need the sweater back
this is not good cuz you're taller than
me okay okay okay the causes eggs smell
like rot
fix my hair okay okay wait okay where do
I put my hands
fix my microphone so to decorate an egg
we need the tablets nope nope there's a
bad light okay cool we've got them and
they're they should be nope
yep just open that up okay there we go
okay now we're gonna place one tablet
into each of the glasses of water here
we go in goes one oh it's so nice yellow
there goes another green what's the next
color
Oh red nope no I gotta put it in this
one hmm
keep going yeah there we go nice nice
blue we don't have any more for those so
we will just set those down now what we
need is maybe can you fix my hair thank
you keep getting away from the
microphone thank you no onions
okay we need to stir these wait all
right so I guess I'm gonna stir this
with a hanger but I hope that I know
that if I mix that you know the other
color it's going to mix it so naturally
I'll use the other end of the hanger
because why not oh it looks like I
didn't mix that one good enough maybe I
should keep going
that's a nice mix good mix it her is a
woman huh
maybe I should yeah okay yeah that's why
I am gotta get the other night it's very
dangerous
okay now what I've got a knife I'm going
to mix this last one up there out there
we go I just have really really bad aim
cool I think that looks mixed enough
that's nice let's put that down
geez no not near my face job I can't
believe I would do that okay the next
thing I'm gonna do I'm gonna cry like
crayon it's no it's not there no I don't
want a job oh I want to get a white
crayon no I want to get a white crayon
the white crayon is over here boy
I think I can reach it if I just if I
just maybe ease my left hand to just
keep reaching down pick it up that's
nice so with the white crayon we're
going to draw on the egg and this will
prevent the dye from getting on the egg
it's a really magical process so right
now I'm writing something oh I just made
a star it looks good
I don't know what that is I'm not sure
my mind sometimes doesn't work well with
my hands and after we've made some nice
art we then put it inside of one oh
there we go into the yellow we're gonna
leave that there like so then we're
gonna grab another one
if you had got our cut crayon I'm good
we had a crayon well this is silly and
we're just gonna draw a little bit more
on it with the white crayon it acts as a
barrier to the egg god that's nice
it's really good it's like I'm Pablo
Picasso my mind is working real fast
cool I'm gonna drop that into another
one and you go yep
there we go in into the green yeah
now we've got more eggs we could do just
a couple more of these yeah we'll just
put that in the blue all right we're
gonna put one in the red right there not
there no that's not what that one
anywhere let's not put that anywhere
let's just that's the wrong two in the
blue why not
okay we've got a couple more here well
this is working out really well we've
got a couple more colors I still would
like to fold in the right in the egg my
hair is stuck in the egg my that's my
hat my hair is in the shell
sure let's put it in the yellow one this
is just going really well let's put some
stickers on shall we
oh god oh god some stickers some
stickers on the eggs oh god I am just
seeing my arm my own arms
okay wait how do we get these eggs out
of here now oh god hold on we got to get
the
hey guys are back cool alright let's
take out maybe the blue one I feel like
it might be looking real good that's the
yellow but my eyes I'm colorblind that's
green but that's fine oh boy let me just
dig in that real good just maybe like
dig from the other sock from yet from
like maybe yep
that's nice oh that looks good Wow yeah
I'm just gonna use my hand I'm just
gonna put my hand right in there and I'm
just gonna you know I'm gonna take
what's mine I'm gonna take what's mine
right now
very that's not even yellow it's fine
just place that right there okay cool
I'm gonna get a sticker these stickers
look good yep right there on that egg we
should hold it up so I could show
everyone it that's not that's cool right
there that sticker looks good that a is
for that looks nice put a couple more
stickers on and maybe we can get out all
that looks so that's supposed to be a
Pegasus dyed yellow I think I'm not sure
I think we might have made a few
mistakes
somewhere along the line that's nice how
about we check and see what's happening
with the blue egg with the blue egg dye
this is not working this is not even
blue the dogs barking okay I'm just
trying big that's cool okay well I'm
making a mess you know what I think I
would like to do that I think I'd like
to hold up this cart yeah Mady okay if
I'm at this year who's here all right
guys I'm gonna now hold up my carton of
eggs and show you what we believe
Matthew
that's nice I'd like to hold it out for
the audience look guys look what a good
job we did that's correct
don't tip any further just yeah okay
you're gonna drop them all thanks for
watching let me know what you like to
see us do next Happy Easter
don't check out Chavez channel and tell
her she being okay bye
okay let's get out of here stop touching
me stop touching me
oh good it's so hot Mattie no Mattie oh
why is he so wild so he'll piss off the
neighbors I feel like these could have
been reversible it's just my little
thing that I noticed during the unboxing
I am definitely always into having some
new Apple watch bands